I'm Jack Horner curator of paleontology
at the Museum of the Rockies the Alan
Grant character from Jurassic Park 1 & 3
is loosely based on me
I first got involved with the Jurassic
Park movies when Steven Spielberg called
me up one day and asked me if I'd like
to work on a movie most of the dinosaurs
that we see in Jurassic world are
dinosaurs we created for the other ones
except for the new dinosaur indominus
rex we have a new attraction and it'll
scare the kids
this would give the appearance that is
he's Swinton made a new dinosaur we
started out with a dinosaur called
therizinosaurus which has big arms and
then add a little t-rex in or
Velociraptor plus using cuttlefish which
is sort of further to camouflage and
infrared well the recipe for indominus
rex it's not only a hybrid of different
kinds of dinosaurs but it's also a
transgenic dinosaur which means that we
could take genetic characteristics from
other kinds of animals and add them
what's really cool about this is the
concept of making a hybrid dinosaur or a
transgenic dinosaur is actually
plausible we can do that today probably
not a good idea
I mean if you want I was really scary
when I would
splice together a t-rex to give it size
and bulk and power and then give it the
bloodthirstiness of maybe a vampire bat
and all he has to do is just slash away
slurp up into blood am I going to do it
am I going to make myself a blood
sucking dinosaur well not likely but I
was thinking about making a
chickenosaurus there's lots going on
where you have you know for laboratories
actually working pretty hard on doing
some of these transformations I think
we're moving right along recently I've
been thinking about you know what kinds
of creatures could we make we could
probably make a unicorn that glows in
the dark we already make
glow-in-the-dark rabbits and other kinds
of animals using genes from jellyfish
all we have to do now is figure out a
way to put a
on a horse and I actually think there's
a pretty easy way to do that as weird as
it sounds I think we can do it I didn't
do it right now